fear not Mandalorian fans everyone's
favourite 50 year old infants will be on
shelves in time for Christmas in some
form or another this tea has announced a
merchandise featuring the child or as
viewers of the Disney Plus series of
affectionately nicknamed it baby Yoda
will be on sale in the weeks leading up
to Christmas according to CNBC the merch
will include apparel and accessories and
while no specific mention was made of
plush toys we simply can't imagine that
there won't be baby Yoda plush toys
sitting under Christmas trees this year
even if they might hit shelves a little
later in the holiday season in case
you've been hiding under a rock since
the Mandalorians debut the Star Wars
series focuses on the titular bounty
hunter who is tasked with bringing in a
target that has proven ridiculously
difficult for members of his nefarious
guild to get their scummy hands on said
target is located under heavily armed
guard at a remote fortress on the harsh
desert planet of avala 7 and with the
help of a bounty hunting droid IG 11 the
Mandalorian is able to navigate as a
half century old infant member of the
same unnamed race as the iconic Jedi
Master Yoda rather than allow IG 11 to
terminate it the Mandalorian dispatches
the Droid setting off one of the oddest
interplanetary buddy adventures of all
time
the silence contemplative force
sensitive shy owed instantly captured
the hearts and minds of viewers because
it is in a word adorable it's revealed
at the conclusion of the Mandalorians
debut episode was a heck of a surprise
so what's the wonder that merge centered
around the floppy ear toss wasn't made
available prior to its premiere but
there's no way Disney didn't know the
extent to which the character would
captivate the series viewers so it seems
pretty likely that the house of mouse
will do its best to make sure that under
every households tree a baby Yoda there
will be
[Music]
this is what was causing all of the fuss
of course Hasbro which holds the license
to produce Star Wars toys has had no
comments and when actual plush toys will
be available in the informed opinion of
one industry insider though failing to
exploit that market would be akin to
tearing up a license to print money
marisa DeBartolo
editor-in-chief of the toy insider told
market watch as long as the merch hits
before the holidays it's going to be a
huge success if it drops before Black
Friday which we expected well a
guaranteed to be gone in an instant
baby Yoda will be the tickle-me-elmo of
2019 just grab yours before it ends up
on eBay no wonder he's laughing all the
way to the bank because North America
has been gripped by Tickle Me Elmo
hysteria it stands to reason that within
a few months of the most you'll be able
to pick up baby Yoda
toys mugs hats and probably anything
else she could conceive of at retail
outlets from department stores all the
way down to your local gas station in
order to score some merch in time for
the holiday though they'll have to know
where to look in the weeks leading up to
Christmas you may want to check the
Parman stores Target Kohl's and Macy's
as well as specialty retailers Zazzle
Hot Topic and box lunch also some
products will be available at the Disney
Store on the website shop Disney calm
and at Disney parks at this point is
being reported that consumers will be
able to pre-order toys including those
of the plush variety over the coming
weeks it's unclear exactly what type of
merchandise is expected to ship in the
coming weeks but again we'd be shocked
if just these goal wasn't to get a plush
baby Yoda into the hands of everybody
who wants one by Christmas now there's
always a chance that the Tickle Me Elmo
comparison could prove to be apt and
that the demand for baby Yoda toys over
the next month could far exceed the
supply given the cuddly critters
explosive popularity in fact we find
this to be pretty likely check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]